what's your source of belief
in situations like this
when the engineering problem is so
difficult there's a lot of experts
many of whom you admire who have failed
in the past yes and
um
a lot of people
you know
a lot of experts maybe journalists all
the kind you know the public in general
have a lot of doubt about whether it's
possible
and you yourself know that even if it's
a non-normal set not an empty set
of success it's still unlikely or very
difficult like where do you go to both
personally
intellectually as an engineer as a team
like for source of strength needed to
sort of persevere through this
and to keep going with the project take
it to completion
a source of strength i i just really
know how i think about things
um
i mean for me it's simply this this is
something that is important to get done
um
and we we should just keep doing it um
or die trying
and i i don't need
a source of strength so quitting is not
even like um
that's not it's not my nature okay and i
i don't
care about optimism or pessimism
that we're gonna get it done
you